[Music]
in 1950 there were two mega cities in
the world
today there are 34
in 15 years time there'll be nearly 50.
really big cities are
great things
they're some of the greatest things that
mankind has ever created
they make people wealthier
and more productive
they make them freer
but the failure to manage the growth of
megacities means they also come with
mega problems
overcrowding
pollution
filth
slums
and it could get much much worse
by 2050 over 6 billion people could be
living in cities
so how could the mega cities of tomorrow
manage some of the biggest challenges of
today
[Music]
cities are growing faster than ever
before
the speed of growth of cities has
enormously increased so
it took london
about 2 000 years to go from a town of
50 000 to a city of about 10 million
people
[Music]
now shenzhen in china
went through that same growth in 30
years
the speed at which cities grow
has become
unprecedented
in 1950 the world's population was 30
urban 70 rural by 2050
it will be the other way round with
almost 70 percent or 6 billion people in
cities
many of the fastest growing cities are
in the developing world with 90 of urban
growth set to occur in sub-saharan
africa and asia
and in these areas megacities cities
with over 10 million inhabitants are
already struggling
mumbai home to over 20 million people
many of whom live in poor conditions due
in part to poor urban planning
i think a lot of the problems that mega
cities have these days are planning
issues it's at the edges of the cities
where there is almost no planning where
things really severely break down
farmers who have tiny plots of land will
sell that plot to a developer and nobody
will be thinking about where the main
road is going to go or where the school
should be
the result
disorganized settlements lacking basic
services
leading to desperate living conditions
there's almost no roads in these
settlements there's sometimes no
electricity
there's no public water supply there are
no sewers
so where can mega cities find
inspiration for a more joined up
approach than mumbai
just 300 miles away is a medabad a city
of 7 million people where they've taken
an innovative approach to urban planning
the city's town planning scheme is
designed to integrate the city's vital
infrastructure as it grows rather than
afterwards
planners identify a wide area to build a
new suburb and requisition a portion of
land from all the farmers in that area
land is set aside for new road grids and
facilities
farmers are handed back a reduced
portion of their original land which
they can sell
their new plots are smaller but worth
more because they will be served by
better facilities
there are certain public goods which the
market
left to itself
will not usually supply for example
social housing public parks schools
often one advantage of the amber about
system is that those things can be built
into the process from the very beginning
so you just get a sort of more equitable
style of sprawl than you would than you
would get otherwise
compared with other indian cities
ahmedabad suburbs are clearly more
organized with planned public services
roads and thousands of affordable homes
there are arguments
there is corruption within the system
there are all sorts of problems but it
does work much much better than anything
else in the developing world
[Music]
smart planning can improve the way
cities grow but a functioning transport
system is essential
greater los angeles with more than 12
million residents is notorious for its
traffic jams and the air pollution they
cause
in 2017 a study found that congestion
cost the city nearly 20 billion dollars
in lost productivity
they've built wider freeways and a light
rail system introduced carpool lanes and
even a smart traffic supercomputer
but so far nothing has unstuck the jam
la's troubles are a cautionary tale for
other growing mega cities
especially in emerging economies where
car use is continuing to rise
but help for some of the world's largest
cities might just come from one of its
smaller ones
the finnish capital helsinki is home to
a startup that's beginning to challenge
the need for private cars
and it's doing it on a whim
wim is a smartphone app which combines
every available mode of transport to
select the best route across the city
what sets wim apart from similar apps is
that a single payment or even a monthly
subscription covers all types of
journeys
from bus and tram trips
to e-scooters city bikes
and even ferries
there is no mode out there that can
compete with car ownership that can give
the same service promises the car has
been delivering but if we put them all
together we start being able to say hey
i can actually guarantee we can get you
there
helsinki is a far cry from the teaming
mega cities of africa or asia but whim
could be an interesting model for them
precisely because it's focused on using
existing modes of transport more
effectively
rather than building expensive new ones
i think it could catch on in
poorer larger more chaotic cities
partly just because everybody has a
smartphone now in those places
it's not impossible to imagine that
something similar could be built in in
somewhere like lagos eventually
perhaps the biggest challenge faced by
the world's mega cities is their waste
by 2050 total waste generation in south
asia will double
in sub-saharan africa it will triple
in mega-cities like lagos or manila
rubbish is either burned buried or left
in the open to rot
as it decomposes it releases greenhouse
gases and chemicals that can contaminate
water supplies
yet there's one solution that's been
around for decades
recycling is not a new thing at all but
in a mega city you need to do it at an
absolutely enormous scale and with a
high degree of sophistication
the city of san francisco produces 300
truckloads of waste every day
here at recycle central they're using
technology that could mark a step change
in how mega cities can reduce the
environmental impact of rubbish
it may not look all that different to
other recycling operations but the big
change here is the scale
recycle central at pier 96 is a
recycling superstructure with conveyor
belts and magnets
and optical and robotic sorters
and every day we separate
550 tons of recycling into 12 different
materials
it's an increasingly automated setup
that utilizes artificial intelligence
technologies to help ensure san
francisco diverts more waste from
landfill than any major city in america
we don't want to waste anything
all that recycled material goes back to
manufacturing facilities to be made into
new products
and that's only half the story
80 miles away they're scaling up an
age-old method for dealing with even
more of the city's waste
composting is very old the romans did it
3000 years ago what's new is that san
francisco is collecting food scraps on a
city-wide basis and turning them into
compost and sending it back to farms so
we're combining something old with
something new
in this plant careful adjustments to
airflow and water help control the
natural rotting of waste to produce
nutrient-rich compost we're creating the
conditions here for the microbial
colonies the microorganisms to do their
job to break this material down into
smaller and smaller pieces
discarded branches from almond trees act
as a natural filter
absorbing the greenhouse gases emitted
during decomposition
the end product is another revenue
stream a high quality compost which is
sold to farms and vineyards across
california
no matter how you manage
waste material there's costs involved
the wonderful thing about recycling and
about composting
is that
you can sell those materials it doesn't
provide enough revenue to pay all the
cost but does bring some revenue back to
your city
these solutions they make great sense in
all cities
this plant is kitted out with the latest
machinery but composting at scale could
also be done with cheaper tools to
address the mountains of organic waste
which pile up in many mega cities
as with so many of the challenges facing
mega cities at their population's trend
ever larger the seeds for the solutions
they'll need are already being sown
in towns and cities across the world but
it's the mega cities very size that
might just prove their greatest asset
mega cities
have outsized problems but the wonderful
thing about mega cities is that they do
assemble
clever people
so mega cities are always going to throw
up these incredibly challenging problems
but they should always
be able to cope with them through brain
power and innovation
[Music]
i'm tom standage deputy editor of the
economist and editor of the world ahead
to read more of our future gazing
coverage click on the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]